well it feels like home
I said
last time I was here
in a sense I know why my ancestors and
many of your relatives left during the
famine
and uh but uh you know when you're here
you wonder why anyone would ever want to
leave
I mean it my Grandpa Finney could also
say every time I walked over when I we
talk about background and Heritage
Ezekiel remember Joey best drop of blood
in you is Irish
or y'all think I'm kidding I'm not
kidding and uh he'd never been to
Ireland but he raised his family with a
fierce pride in our Irish ancestry
a pride that spoke to the history that
binds us and the values that unite us
and it's important to remember there's
the values of the United States